One-fourth divided by one-third can also
be written as one-fourth times 3 over 1.
1 times 3 equals 3, and 4 times 1 equals
4, so that gives us three-fourths.
One-third divided by one-fourth can also
be written as one-third times 4 over 1.
1 times 4 gives us 4,
and 3 times 1 is 3.
This is important.
Notice that the order matters.
One-fourth divided by one-third is not
the same thing as one-third divided by
one-fourth.
Five-twelfths divided by one-fourth
can be written as
five-twelfths times 4 over 1.
5 times 4 equals 20, and
12 times 1 equals 12.
This needs to be simplified.
We know that 20 and
12 share a common factor of 4.
20 can be written as 4 times 5, and
12 can be written as 4 times 3.
I divide out the 4 from the top and
the bottom, and that leaves five-thirds.
Two-ninths divided by three-fifths can
also be written as two-ninths times
five-thirds.
2 times 5 gives us 10,
and 9 times 3 gives us 27.
This is already simplified,
so this is our answer.